en vídeos previos revisamos brevemente
que son los mercados de divisas en
particular hablamos del mercado de
divisas entre el dólar estadounidense y
el yuan chino lo que vamos a hacer en
este vídeo será pensar en la misma idea
pero en términos de gráficas y de los
modelos económicos que estamos
acostumbrados a ver en un curso
introductorio de macroeconomía de modo
que en este vídeo nos vamos a enfocar en
el mercado de divisas para el yuan chino
vamos a pensar en términos de curvas de
oferta y demanda puede ser un poco
confuso porque vamos a pensar en el
precio del yuan en términos de otra
moneda en este caso del dólar aunque
podemos hacerlo en términos de otra
moneda como la libra el euro o cualquier
otra esto puede ser un poco confuso
porque vamos a pensar en términos de
monedas en ambos ejes primero veamos el
eje horizontal que para otros mercados
este es nuestro eje de cantidad y aquí
también vamos a tener la cantidad vamos
a pensar en la cantidad cantidad de
joanes chinos
y en nuestro eje vertical vamos a pensar
esencialmente en el precio del yuan
chino pero como pensamos en el precio de
una moneda bueno pensamos en términos de
otra moneda y para el propósito de este
vídeo esa otra moneda será el dólar
estadounidense entonces aquí tendremos
dólares estadounidenses por johann chino
los animo a que pausa en el vídeo
piensen profundamente sobre porque aquí
tenemos dólares estadounidenses por
johann chino y no yuanes chinos por
dólar estadounidense y también piensen
porque aquí puse la cantidad de iones
chinos en lugar de la cantidad de
dólares estadounidenses porque este es
el mercado de divisas para el yuan chino
pude haber hecho otra gráfica para el
mercado de divisas del dólar
estadounidense en cuyo caso mi cantidad
hubiera sido el dólar estadounidense y
entonces hubiera pensado que tanto de
otra moneda vale por un dólar
estadounidense tal vez que tantos iones
chinos por un dólar estadounidense
este es el caso contrario estoy en el
mercado del yuan chino entonces pensemos
en las curvas de oferta y demanda y cómo
funcionan bueno imaginemos que la gente
ofrece muy pocos dólares por cada yo en
chino en ese mundo no muchas personas
estarían dispuestas a convertir sus
bienes en dólares no los ofrecerían para
convertirlos en dólares estadounidenses
si el precio del yuan chino es bajo la
cantidad de iones chinos será baja y si
el precio que las personas están
dispuestas a pagar en dólares sube bueno
más y más personas estarían dispuestas a
hacer transacciones
entonces nuestra curva de oferta y aquí
estamos hablando de oferta para ello en
chino parece que se incrementa en tanto
que la gente está dispuesta a pagar más
por esos yuanes chinos y esto es igual
que en muchos mercados que hemos visto
antes es un poco menos intuitivo porque
estamos pensando en una moneda en
términos de otra moneda
ahora qué pasa con la curva de demanda
bueno la curva de demanda es como otras
curvas de demanda que hemos visto si el
precio del yuan chino es alto
bueno poca gente va a quererlos y si el
precio de johann chino en términos de
dólares es más y más bajo más gente va a
querer los iones chinos y podrían decir
oye están más baratos en términos de
dólares estadounidenses entonces así es
como se vería la curva de demanda y como
pueden imaginar este punto es el punto
de equilibrio y nos va a indicar nuestro
tipo de cambio de equilibrio podríamos
llamarle tipo de cambio de equilibrio e
iu a este punto podríamos llamarle
cantidad de equilibrio q así que por
ejemplo digamos que esta es la cantidad
que cambia de manos en un período de
tiempo digamos que por día digamos que
nuestra cantidad de equilibrio es igual
a mil yuanes a esto lo voy a llamar
curso 1
estos números son muy bajos en los
mercados cambiarios reales podríamos
estar hablando de miles de millones o
billones o en algunos casos de trillones
de distintas monedas pero digamos que
para nuestro caso la cantidad actual de
intercambio de equilibrio por día es de
mil yuanes y digamos que este tipo de
cambio es un 1 es igual a 10 centavos
por johann 10 centavos o un décimo de
dólar estadounidense por johann chino
este es nuestro tipo de cambio actual
ahora digamos que por alguna razón de
repente los estadounidenses se interesan
cada vez más por convertir su moneda tal
vez porque quieran invertir en china o
tal vez si los chinos dijeran oigan
estadounidenses vengan a comprar
propiedades en china mucha gente estaría
interesada qué pasaría entonces bueno la
demanda de joanes se incrementaría
porque sólo puedes comprar propiedades
en china con yuanes no con dólares qué
pasaría aquí bueno la curva de demanda
se movería a la derecha como lo hemos
visto
si a esta la llamamos de uno entonces
podríamos tener una nueva curva de
demanda que se vería algo así de 2 ahora
qué pasaría si nuestro tipo de cambio no
se modifica bueno si éste es nuestro
tipo de cambio y no se modifica ahora se
va a exigir una mayor cantidad de joanes
que lo que se está ofreciendo en esta
situación los estadounidenses en
realidad no necesariamente los
estadounidenses sino cualquier persona
que tenga dólares estadounidenses
estarían demandando más de mil yuanes
por día tal vez 1.500 yuanes o lo que
sea lo que naturalmente veríamos es que
el precio del yuan en términos del dólar
estadounidense va a aumentar hasta
llegar a un nuevo punto de equilibrio y
en el primer vídeo cuando hablamos de la
intuición de mercados de divisas
hablamos de la razón por la que esto
ocurre entonces obtenemos un nuevo
equilibrio justo aquí aquí tenemos a sub
2 y una nueva cantidad de equilibrio
a esta cantidad q 2 nuestra nueva
cantidad de equilibrio q 2 podría ser
1.200 yuanes por día contra mil yuanes
por día y nuestro nuevo tipo de cambio
de equilibrio tal vez ahora sería de 15
centavos por johann en lugar de 10
centavos por johann es un panorama
general podemos pensar en el mercado de
divisas en muchos sentidos como lo hemos
visto en otros mercados en macroeconomía
se necesita un poco de intuición para
pensar en el mercado de una moneda en
términos de otra hasta el próximo vídeo